hello everybody and welcome to part 9 of
let's play penumbra overture um I still
don't know how to get through this thing
I failed miserably at the last try of
using an explosive container but maybe I
didn't get it close enough so I'm gonna
try this trick again and not screw it up
how about that huh no bonk okay
and pick it up and drop it gently over
and run like hell Wow nope that is some
strong wood okay that's what she said
haha all right oh no oh no it's
happening again
all right no it won't I won't let it be
on the fast to the right there should be
a hole or path HAP's an access point to
reach further into the mind all right
got that can't do that found what I
think is a storeroom but it's blocked
from the other side okay can't go in
there
found a great door leading deeper into
the complex but it's barricade with a
piece of wood on the other side need
some way to shift it all three things
mean I can't go places that's fantastic
all right oh right okay thinking there
some way to shift it I've tried
explosives and that didn't work which
you think it would but it did not all
right I was running away from the dog so
maybe there was some part around here
that you know I miss ah oh yeah
I'll go get a sneak attack +2 bonus ah
what's the bonus
ah yeah get get back all right into the
ground get out of here nope don't even
try to get up yeah run away [ __ ] I'm so
great oh don't even try it
fam yeah
ah oh it's another one ah what no [ __ ]
Oh get out of here guy here a guy here
get out of here get out of here yeah oh
yeah oh oh yeah
oh I win every time I come back here
come back here come back here oh yeah oh
no no oh no I'm so tough but I'm so
tough yeah whatever
ah
all right back here why ah okay oh my
god did I lose part I lose I lost
progress [ __ ] me
okay all right okay um oh I'll do I'll
repeat my actions again Herbert herb
oh I I think I'll go to the storage room
oh it's over there oh yeah oh it's a
story all know is blocked
okay oh shut up Doug
ah he's um Oh eyes [ __ ] ciliary shaft
right left right left left
oh shut up
I hate you so much dogs I hate you
oh oh it's just a great Oh No
oh I jotted down a note oh it's a dog oh
oh I'm scared oh you're gonna run in
your [ __ ] formation that's fantastic
let me just walk you please please just
let me hit you oh let me hit you come on
why what why that is ridiculous dog you
know how stupid you look do you know if
you don't I'm gonna tell you you look as
stupid as Billy does and I don't even
know what he looks like
oh come on it's just this let me here
take some of that take that with you and
just burn in hell
oh yes of course I must get out of here
oh yeah super stealth mode yeah oh shut
up don't call another one of your
friends oh come on
get out of here out of here out of here
out of here that was dead
you're soon gonna be dead get out of
here I said out
ah come on out oh come here just come
here what the [ __ ] was that John don't
pull a Billy on me
get out yes and one more and tell me
you're dead oh please
Oh finally ah oh my god oh god oh man
that was ridiculous oh where one failed
maybe too will with the other one oh
yeah oh yeah oh my god oh alright
no Marik I'm here I said yeah
come here Oh get back there don't you be
doing that alright
Boop I said poop or Boop there we go
okay running away do it nope ah ha fail
fail fail fail yeah why did I have to go
up there and find a bunch of those
things if I wasn't gonna use them why
why tell me why
bet you can't cuz there was no reason oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy yeah alright
got my notes saying I got three places I
can't go into I got a door that I can't
shift open Oh life is good life is good
what leads here nothing oh ah yes
oh yeah some place I haven't been Oh
totally not gonna go [ __ ] me oh never
mind never mind
false alarm false hope alarm oh what's
in here something useful
nope nothing nothing nothing at all
all right a bender excavation there's
another dog down there but he's not
bothering me
it's another thing that has nothing
useful in it why are they even there why
why would why would they even be there
why would they be there I don't know I
don't know oh I don't know I don't know
I don't know uh some kind of altar
fantastic oh hello oh yeah pretty high
not for me
awesome so great yes yes yes yes yes yes
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah oh so
strong what the hi
what all right nothing Oh the ladder the
ladder the ladder ladder yeah oh yeah oh
yeah got it just oh hang on there get on
there oh I got a climb up okay climb up
got to climb up got to climb up get up
here get hold this alright ah yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah okay
climb up ha I'm already high ha ha oh
another letter another letter
all right what are gonna use a clamp can
I use you use you table no no no all
right I can figure this out oh yeah
altar up ramp it up [ __ ]
ramp it up all right gonna get smart all
up in this [ __ ]
altar mob but more like place for mark
to show how smart he is and yes my name
is mark if you didn't guess by my
channel name it is mark thank you Oh
what am i doing come on come on yeah Oh
who's the best me oh I felt I saw that
you didn't just get that away from me I
I saw it oh so smart
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] ah yeah okay left right
left
Oh what's this eggs yep nothing lays
eggs bat build that big campy mammalian
that's because the only mammal that lays
eggs is the platypus Oh Oh yucky
ah what the [ __ ] huh what the [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] I got it oh what the
[ __ ] is that
what what what is going on what why why
music why music why aah
just minor ah [ __ ] go away get away get
away go away I gotta [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
up the ass
I got [ __ ] you yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] oh oh how
did that not kill you
paraffins in my eyes what what paraffin
wax oh I had another dead end
ah oh no no no what the hell ah
all right I'm gonna pause it here
Farge ah fudge darn it
alright that's it for part 9 I will see
you guys in part 10 and I will not make
a fool out of myself again bye bye